so it's lovely to see you here today
charlotte at collector mania how you
been enjoying it your first Colin isn't
it yeah no this is my first time so it
was a bit overwhelming at first but
everyone's been really lovely so it's
just been it's been nice to meet people
and yeah I've had a glorious time and
you've had a very interesting season on
Game of Thrones as well haven't you
what's been your favorite scene that
you've had so far I mean this is
probably a bit controversial that I
actually liked and you see the most like
I I find those scenes really empowering
it was a really cool scene as well it
wasn't like a traditional sex scene and
I got to fight it was like wild and
feral and so yeah that was kind of my
favorite but I recognize that some ugly
not a normal thing to say that's an
interesting relationship Miranda's got
with ramsey isn't it what do you think
of it I love it like firstly it's so
much fun to play like having that kind
of like wild passion is really fun I
think that's why I loved that scene so
much was like animalistic also I think
like that's why she behaves as awfully
as she does because she loves him
ultimately and she just wants his
affection and approval so yeah I it's
basically it's just it's just a love
story that's that's what's going on
there really dark love stories know
exactly fairytale land are we here no
Gary different from go with Thrones and
you also reunited son so we see on
didn't you what was it like playing that
think that was pretty dog wasn't it
those ones are fun cuz it was just
playing with Sophie and like we were
really good friends so we had a really
good time doing it but it it was fun to
just Miranda getting to do some acting
and just kind of taunting for Sophie so
I really enjoyed that but it was also
quite a nice contrast between you get
the like the raw visceral Miranda with
the ones character and then getting to
like play or sweet it was was a real
contrast that was really fun for me yeah
she was very much playing the kind of
butter wouldn't melt in the mouth wasn't
she but you know Sansa got a little bit
of [ __ ] effort didn't she when you had
that bath see yeah yeah there was a bit
but actually that's what I think makes
her more scary is when she's like
pretending to be really sweet and it's
not
really unnerving like we played around
with that seen quite a lot and in the
end it was like we want her to just it
to be sickly sickly sweet and that makes
it all the more scary because you know
it's just a whole bunch of terrible
machination yeah because we know what's
been going on in the background with
Miranda
even though censor doesn't know have
this background with her what was it
like filming that scene where you were
with Sophie and there was the bath going
on and Sophie and no sensor was being
kind of Stefan making her mark wasn't
she against Miranda it was it was really
because that scene had like a real kind
of two halves the first half was all
that like Miranda was in power and it
was really fun and I was just kind of
yeah toying with Sophie and then gets
her in her place but we had a via we did
it for a day and it was just really fun
we just messed about with it the bath
was really nice it was oily like it's
basically like a beauty treatment I was
cute I like spa on Game of Thrones it
was really the water was really really
nice I was kind of jealous but she got
to be in the bathtub like give me some
thought yeah it was fun maybe you'll get
one in future who knows
part of my Ryder yeah oily bath please
and what do you think of the cuz
obviously it wasn't a scene that the
Miranda was involved in but it's a scene
that's always even quite controversial
in Game of Thrones as season hasn't it
the scene with Sansa's wedding night
with Ramsay and Theon what was your
reaction to that and what do you think
about other people's reactions that
they've had I think what was really
great about that scene is the way they
shot it off Alfie it made it again
almost more shocking because you could
just see it in his reaction and I
thought his performance in that scene
was incredible he's such a brilliant
brilliant actor healthy and I I kind of
loved that it was being played off of
that and actually you didn't really see
anything and kind of more shocking
because you had to imagine it and
yeah it was I mean it was horrible to
watch but in a really really good way I
mean what do you think some people have
kind of said oh I'm not going to watch
Game of Thrones anymore after this or
you know maybe it was too far and some
people understand it the point of which
they killed Shireen that's when you
should be being like what but like in
the books that that's seen with them
with Ramsey and Jane Pauley exactly it's
much much more graphic so really that
was Game of Thrones being quite tame I
would say it's interesting isn't it you
mentioned Shireen there as well which is
a harrowing scene but they chose again
to shoot off that character most the
time and take the reaction shots I think
that just makes it much much more it's
just more heroine when you're having to
imagine it and seeing what it does to
these other characters which is well
that's the real like trauma in it is
what yeah how affects everyone else and
we had an interesting reaction I think a
lot of people were were were interested
by the reaction we had from Seles
Serene's mother as opposed to father
Stannis CERN I wondered if you know what
kind of if we'll have any surprises
coming out with Miranda like that things
that we wouldn't necessarily expect from
her you know what I'm not saying yes who
knows it's a mystery I'm saying nothing
how likely are you to see you in a
season six and what we what would you
like to see for your character if we do
see you going forward hypothetically if
I were in season six I I mean I really
can't say anything but I would love I
love would love to build the
relationship with Ramsay because I think
it's a really interesting one I love all
the stuff that I've had with Sophie to
be honest more of the same I freaking
George what I had in season five so any
more of that would be amazing but I am
no liberty to tell you anything now as
Miranda the character I mean what kind
of revenge do you think she'd like to
get on Sun suffered for taking her man
actually everything like what's the
thing about Miranda is that no like a
lot of girls have tried to get Ramsay
before and she's taken them down and I
think the fact that there's someone who
might have stolen some of his affection
is pretty horrific to her so I think
she's learnt from someone
whose emblem is flaying I feel that she
would probably go all out on any kind of
revenge yeah yeah I wouldn't want to
cross her basically she's really really
good with a bow and arrow we have some
amazing deaths on the show on Game of
Thrones if you could go out in any way
how would you like Miranda to get the
chop oh oh this is so much um I think I
would probably do you know what I would
like to go out in a way that I could
come back as a white Walker I would like
to be a like yeah yeah that big show was
so cool last time that's what I want I
want to come back I wanted because
Russia as well I think is a freaking
awesome awesome actress I loves that so
I'll come back as like her minion she
can kill me oh my god that could be find
awesome June I think we would really be
quite powerful together and I'm gonna
speak to David and Dan this evening and
make sure that happens tell me a little
bit about filming cuz I'm guessing
you're mostly filming in Belfast today
did all of my stuff in Belfast and I
loved it there like it's they're so
welcoming it's so much fun like the
food's awesome and because most of the
cast film at in Belfast
it means everyone's there like I I
filmed all my stuff with a wand and
Alfie and Sophie but a lot of time I was
there like KITT was there and Hanna
Marie's there and like that was really
fun because it's just nice to get to
John Bradley as well as their a lot when
we're filming like they're really nice
so I'm not really nice little family out
there so I I have a blast it's the best
one ever the other characters what would
you like to see happen in other
storylines going forward obviously were
kind of like at a limit of the books as
we have them at the moment aren't we
I'd really like to see the de niro
storyline mix more with everyone else
like if you've had it a bit with Tyrion
so far but I'd love to see actually what
happens if she gets to King's Landing
that would be pretty awesome to be
honest and all of it I like to want
everyone to like mix it up that would be
really really fun maybe she'll go and I
don't know flame Stannis yeah that'll be
great like
Sammis I'm like I'm done with you now go
and be flamed well if you got coming up
apart from Game of Thrones I've just
done an episode of something with death
and paradise there's a BBC cop dramas
I've been Guadeloupe for four weeks and
which was really nice and I've got a
film about to come out called north and
south which is a kind of crime thriller
romeo juliet storyline but and yeah
we're going to the Edinburgh Film
Festival to premiere it which will be
amazing and I like it yeah it's really
like it's really cool and it's it's like
yes it's a gangster film and lots of
people die but also it's got a real
heart to it which makes it a little bit
different I think it was last year when
Edinburgh that and I think is it miss
you already as well you've got that will
come out I think towards the end of the
year I think but yeah that was really
really fun Catherine Hardwicke is a
total babe so we had a lot of fun on
that so I play the young version of drew
Barrymore so it's just pretty wife
pretty wild basically yeah it's been
lovely talking to you Charlotte thanks
so much your time and enjoy your time in
Edinburgh as well well thank you very
much
you